[Music]
[Applause]
un carrefour is the one of the majority
Tyler in France
sociability
cloud providers Google cloud you puta
Delta and mordeita ADN de target is to
have more and more State
[Music]
OK
cloudrider
customization but more  flexible
[Music]
project on Awa
organization for all the project all the
deta 7
Ford table the metatata on the
tableurs insecence
time but it finish i think
imagine you do table by table data set
by data 7 compagnie like mind and the
one from Guillaume a  the lot of stable
hourdait remember what I Sayen induction
design this architecture yes
the script lotov task in clawtask Enzy
in parallel must
other inpons to on the same happy dings
all request the metatata
7 index table
[Music]
containers
base sound container all switch price
popular
Picasso
enyxcale automatic
il fut un look
tootion
first generation
Uka le process on dit one recreest
of tennis
cladre du canal competitor processing  on
the same stance dove process in the
feeling
exactly
parallel processing of the task on
frame run again
s
of time inaps to do of Job Sow that's
good news because remember what I say
normalis yes lava more and more
state say data warehouse today  next Mans
nextes to seed atbity for du futur will
be ok we all Sodi quiz de Morning
whispenso another great news for you
bottle so for me
nolshovs twenty-five pour sanless it is
very great so let me give you
anotherview of True bad before date à
josman to say where are this results
measure basicali in cloud monitoring
looking at the locks begining end of the
job and we do the report for you to be
there with you today
evaluation you can see
different
[Music]
architecture we
UPS password and server
cost a fact at the yield Wayne use
solution on the cloud differ
scale to zero
the scalabity isos base on the number of
free quest is you
use
seepy you
time and you don't scale so much
the differe  rence with cladron
to zero buzz the auto-sceller is the
number of free Quest tattoo and become
loto
scale verifas from from the instance
all more than seven instincts
of
Coste and speed
hollywan difference between star warless
and holder architecture or Legacy hors
standard architecture et un  day Antoine
bonus forest
bonus uses our technical one bad
very important Furious saw of choice
that you will made and it basicli of
conclusion of this presentation is
internal carrying verrine of what we
call dear of
different responsibilities of birthday was the one with
interms of contrast  of responsibilities
providers ok he fire of VM five prefer
having of possibilities all
customizoming battle so have of
mission all
update of VM yeah if iOS cloud run it
is not my job to do that that to Google
ferry important
[Music]
[Music  ]
twitter linkedin of one
riches Antoine
[Applause]
[Music]